The Joe Rogan experience,
so we're approaching like the place we're going to do the afternoon,
you know,
landing spot,
which is just kind of sky deck overlooking the jungle.
And I wanted to take my shoes off as I walked up there.
So I just fucking did it.
I took my shoes off,
didn't worry about the mosquitoes and that felt great.
Just feeling the grass and the mud on my feet.
It was a short walk.
So there wasn't any crazy shit going on in the,
in the brush or anything I had to worry about.
We get up there and um,
I go to lie down and I had taken again,
I'd taken the most,
what you might've taken at any point ever.
So I'm more blasted than I had been the whole trip because I got eight ounces
instead of six.
And I go to lie down and I'm pondering this idea of choice a lot and fears and
feeling pretty good because everything that's happened,
I was passed these tests and I see this little ant crawling towards me to my
right hand side and I look and I go,
fuck,
there's an aunt coming.
And so I totally broke my train of thought.
Stood straight up,
and then I look back at that and I just realized,
Holy Shit,
I just let that little fucking aunt have the power over me to make me sit up.
I lose my train of consciousness and completely move on his behalf.
And it wasn't like a deadly poisonous and it was just an ant and I.
Then I thought to myself,
how many other these little things that are truly ants in our existence,
fears,
worries,
Paranoia's relationships that you feel crunchy about in this certain way or
crunchy.
I like something that's uncomfortable to you in a situation or that you're
projecting and you're simulator is worried about these little things when in
reality or no more than these ants which are harmless,
caused you to make,
to choose actions that aren't in your best interest,
you know,
and we,
because we give them power,
we give them the power over us to make us move.
They do have power
and they could do just as good.
I mean they can have a show.
You did it from your fucking living room 12 years ago and look at you today
and if let's say that they somehow coopt us and we sell out,
right?
They'll some,
someone else's company also replaced Alex Jones.
He's waiting.
He's in Austin,
Texas.
You say you're the number one,
but I've got the statistics.
I've got the documents right here,
but show you're a liar.
You're a new world order puppet.
He seems like he's out there working for the people.
He's not working for the people.
He worked for MSNBC.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you don't get to Msnbc unless you sell your soul to David Ickes reptilians.
That was awesome.
I've never,
I've never heard you do that.
That's,
that was amazing.
I've known that dude for a long time.
I've,
Alex Jones in 1999.
I did a,
a DVD in Austin,
Texas and Alex Jones and I put on Bush masks.
I was a Bush Jr.
He was bush senior and we,
uh,
we,
we were these outfits and ran around the capital and it was called the live from
the belly of the beast.
It was rigHt before bush senior got elected.
And uh,
I've,
I've known him for even before then.
I've known that guy for a long time.
My theory is that alex is a false operation.
Really?
Yeah.
Is there a real,
a real theory?
Kind of half kidding.
Half serious.
But you say that because you're trying to fuck with me.
What he's trying to do right now is coal up my mind.
I'm sitting here in austin,
Texas.
I'm smoking cigarettes and drinking whiskey.
I'm getting fucking crazy.
I'm trying to protect people from the government as black helicopters.
Their flight over my dodge charger.
That's fucking funny.
Tom rhodes pissing this thing.
That's not the bathroom.
Yeah,
that's not the bathroom.
He's in there.
I've done that a lot.
Have you?
Bingo is caught me so many times trying to go into the closet and the hotel room
to take a piss that you go,
well that's the amount of times you've woken up and found me how many times
they've pissed off over my own shit and never knew about it.
I'm trying to remember.
I do it all the time.
The humidity,
I guess.
I'm trying to remember who told me this story,
but somebody opened up the drawer and they pissed on their sock drawer.
They open up,
they went to their dresser and they pulled their sock drawer open and they just
pissed in there and I'm like,
what the fuck did you think your sock drawer was?
The toilet.
I've been on the.
I'm sure you've done this dog peed in the corner of a hotel.
That's why we're talking about.
We saw you go through the wrong door thinking you're going to win when you peed
in the corner of a lot of hotel.
A few of them just being plastered,
like signed it.
I was there.
How many times bingos caught me doing that versus how many times she didn't wake
up that I did that and didn't know I did that.
That's those extra two shots.
Well,
your brain says it's over.
doug stanhope you say,
fuck it is.
I was plastered in Ireland years ago and I went out the room door.
I thought I was going into.
I was just drunk and half awake.
I just needed to pee and I'm in the fucking hallway naked and I was banging on
the door and my hand girlfriend get come.
What the fuck are you doing out there again?
Did that mother fucking door?
We already have this on a podcast.
Hennigan did that right there.
My manager and Henry Phillips both have stories walking out thinking they're
going into the bathroom,
walking out naked and the door shuts me.
Amanda both naked in the fucking hallway going.
Then you instantly become john ritter.
I haven't been.
There's no way.
That's not comedy.
You know?
I don't have identification.
If you do like a 20 year bid in a hotel,
you're working in a hotel for 20 years.
Some who's coming down naked.
How many dudes come down naked during your entire career holding their cock and
balls is going?
Brian,
when he went into a like a locker,
a housekeeping door that was open,
grabbed a a sheet or whatever,
put it over his dick.
I walked down to the hotel and they just gave him the key.
He didn't.
They didn't say id or anything.
Ideology is.
I mean,
I,
I don't remember who said it,
but it's,
it's the enemy of free thinking,
[inaudible].
You get in these ideological clusters and then anything outside of this thing,
these predetermined patterns of behavior that you've done to subscribe to
anything becomes forbidden.
It becomes you.
You can't even entertain it.
You can't even approach the idea.
You see it with everything you see with atheism.
You see it with,
you see it with any isms,
with feminism,
with the men's rights.
You see it with people who subscribe to the right people,
subscribed to the left.
Any variables that don't fit into their equation that they've already suBscribed
to,
they don't want to be labeled as that other side and anytime they don't want to
be labeled,
they start ignoring any evidence or any ideas that don't fit within this really
rigid description.
That's exactly right.
I mean that is.
You hit the nail on the head,
joe.
Weird.
Exactly right.
People get locked into these ideological paradigms and then from that point on,
basically their perspective as modified more by emotion and rationality more by
their feelings rather than real information.
You're the only person that's ever come in,
sat down and said,
oh,
this is good.
I'm getting a cortisol rush.
He said,
you're getting a cortisol rush from the feeling of about.
Actually,
I could have gotten a little more detail,
but please do.
You know,
so that feeling of anxiety,
you know,
that lIke you get before you go onstage,
I mean,
you're a comedian,
I'm sure you're familiar with that.
You actually are expressing a chemical called dane orphan and uh,
this is an endogenous chemical in your brain and it binds to something called
the kappa opioid receptor.
It's kinda like the counter of the endorphin which binds to the new opioid
receptor.
So the endorphins are the feel good.
Well,
it's nemesis is the dynorphins,
which is that anxiety,
like feeling.
So,
but here's the interesting part,
that anxiety,
like feeling that you feel before you're going to do something like you're
really,
that you care about or that's kind of anxiety provoking for me.
Public speaking does it,
I,
I get it right before I'm going to do it,
you know,
give a talk or something,
um,
or do a podcast in front of,
you know,
500,000 people.
Um,
so that dynorphins binding to the cap opioid receptor.
What it does is it upregulates the mule opioid receptor so that after you get
that anxiety feeling,
you have a better endorphin rush because you upregulate the new opioid receptors
which bind to the endorphins,
the feel good ones,
and you actually become sensitized to them.
So there's a biological mechanism by which having that anxiety actually does you
good.
So it's kind of like a stress at first,
but then later on you're,
you get,
do you feel better and you're more relaxed.